you may be benched worshipers of the
beam it has been my pleasure to Shepherd
in a triumphant New Era where with every
Victory the being grows stronger
tonight we shall summon the almighty
being allowing us to blot out the
Western sky it's Beauty never again will
sack town be thrust Back Into Darkness
an intruder
it can't be
the prodigal son has returned Tyrese
I've come to shut off that damn thing
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
ready for that sweet revenge
I'm just focused on passing right now
yes
[Applause]
brother Halliburton have you come to
embrace the beam
that's rude very well beam grant us to
the power of the pistol office
oh I think Corner Shooters buddy
no one shoots faster than me
I don't know what I'm doing
I'm getting too old for this
book
nothing like homemade red velvet
[Music]
now we summon the almighty beef you're
in my spot
there are no spots in the eyes of the
bean
look into the beam Tyrese never
no
oh
yo
[Music]
the beam I go by many names some call me
the almighty being some call me stupid
and ironic
I hear you've come to destroy me what I
wanted revenge for being cast out and
approved to everyone I'm not a fake hero
Ali Serbia against everyone now
you were a hero here and you are a hero
in Indianapolis just because the view
shines doesn't mean you don't shine you
need
find your own being find my own path
[Music]
you ready for that sweet revenge
where are you going
that's someone else's problem let's find
our own
I was not expecting that answer to be
that deep you good bro
[Music]
the beam from the north is too powerful
we must offer a sacrifice to protect the
cat
[Music]
yo whoa whoa hey